c'est ce qui me choque en fait en tant
que parlementaires européens et de voir
par ailleurs la commission européenne
son fonctionnement moi je regardais 40%
des documents la commission européenne
était à la base rédigé en français en
1997 mais il y en a plus que 5 % en 2014
donc vous voyez et au fur et à mesure
les documents il ya eu un glissement
vers l'anglais parce que les
parlementaires laisse faire parce que
les autorités laissent faire
quand je vois que quand vous avez des
directions de la commission des
directions générales la commission
européenne
quand vous regardez les grandes
directions de la commission européenne
je pense par exemple à celle de la
migration qui ne sont accessibles qu'en
anglais celle de la coopération
internationale et de développement celle
de l'environnement celle de
l'élargissement celle du commerce donc
toutes ces directions générales de la
commission européenne si vous allez sur
leur sied tout est en anglais
regardez à aujourd'hui il ya un sujet
qui occupe tous nos compatriotes qui
sont les informations sur les vaccins
l'agencé européenne du médicament
n'était accessible qu'en anglais c'est
inacceptable et c'est pour ça que un
moment il faut taper du poing sur la
table
[Musique]